And it faces the main road
to Jerusalem.
This is a story about
what happened here in 1948.
We are only 750 people.
And everybody knows each other.
It was a black spot in the history.
That history has been
carefully concealed...
purposefully distorted, and in the West,
largely forgotten.
They put our village as an example
of what they can do.
The massacre in this village
was one of many
in a series of catastrophic events...
that became known as
the Nakba.
When hundreds of thousands
of Palestinians
were violently displaced
from their homeland...
in order to create
the state of Israel.
“In May of 1948, a new Jewish state
Israel was born in a bath of blood.”
The borders of Palestine have been
changed forcefully over time.
But historically, this region has been home
to Palestinians for centuries
with hundreds of villages and thriving cities.
One of them being the central city
of Jerusalem...
with holy sites important to Jewish
Christian and Muslim people.
By the late Ottoman Empire,
Palestinians living here
were overwhelmingly Muslim
with minority Christian and
Jewish native populations, too.
But regardless of religion
Palestinians were often
referred to as Arabs.
People of the Arabic speaking world
despite their distinctive culture.
Palestinians have long distinguished
themselves as Ahl Filastīn...
or the people of Palestine.
They developed a distinctive
Arabic accent.
They developed regional food, regional dress,
and family ties.
But by the time World War I began...
several key political forces
were competing for control of these lands.
First, there was a growing Arab
political movement...
looking for independence from
the Ottoman Empire
in hopes of a unified Arab state
that would include Palestine.
Then there were Zionists
a political group that had one main goal:
The creation of a Jewish state.
Zionism was a response to
an increasingly brutal climate
for Jewish people, particularly
in Europe and Russia...
where there was a massive wave
of antisemitism...
including large scale attacks
in the late 1800s and early 1900s.
After briefly considering other areas
for a new state
including Uganda and Argentina...
Zionist leaders decided on Palestine
because of its connection to early religious history.
But there was a third key group
with political interests here.
The British.
Control of the region would
allow them to expand
their spheres of influence and protect
trade routes to India.
During World War I, since both
the British
and the Arab independence movement
wanted Palestine...
they decided to go after
the Ottomans together
with an important pledge.
Through a series of letters in 1916
an Arab leader and a British official agreed
that if Arabs would help the British
fight the Ottomans
and give the British economic and other
foreign privileges in Arab lands...
in return, the British would recognize and support
an independent Arab state.
Soon the Arabs started
doing their part
in revolting against
the Ottomans
making it easier for the British to move in.
But the next year the British issued
a new declaration
and betrayed the Arabs.
“In 1917, Lord Allenby conquered
the Holy Land...
and the Jews were promised
a national home in Palestine.”
Without consulting the native
Palestinian population...
the British issued what's known as
the Balfour Declaration:
Supporting the establishment
in Palestine
of a national home for
the Jewish people.
So instead of supporting
the idea of Palestine
as part of a unified and independent
Arab state...
the British pledged to help secure this land
for Zionists.
It was a strategic move.
This declaration opened up a pathway for Britain
to gain power in Palestine.
Under the guise
that it was supporting the self-determination
of another people...
of a people in Palestine...
who don't reside there yet.
As for Palestine's majority
Arab population
the declaration referred to them as
non-Jewish communities...
who would be given civil
and religious rights...
but not political rights.
A few years later, after World War I ended
Britain gained control of Palestine
through a mandate...
that also required them
to put the Balfour plans
for Jewish settlement in motion.
And they did.
Between 1922 and 1931
the Jewish population
more than doubled.
The migration helped the
Zionist movement gain steam.
And a slogan took off.
“A land without people for,
a people without land.”
And it sends a message to Western leaders...
that the people who had been living
in Palestine for generations...
could just be easily moved elsewhere.
The idea was that those inhabitants
weren't a people
with ties to that land.
Palestine was, of course,
a land with a people.
In 1931, there were more than 850,000
Palestinian Arabs in the region,
still the vast majority.
But with the rise of Hitler and the Nazi Party in particular...
“Hate became a rallying call.”
Jewish flight from Europe
became even more urgent.
And Palestine started to see
the biggest wave of Jewish emigration yet.
Violence broke out, rooted in
tensions over land.
Jewish settlers purchased
swaths of fertile land
and evicted tenant farmers
creating a crisis of hundreds of thousands
of landless, dispossessed
Palestinian-Arabs.
Though Palestinians fiercely rebelled against
both British colonial forces
and Jewish settlers
they were brutally crushed
by the British.
They put in Palestine
more troops to repress that rebellion
than they had stationed in India at that time.
All of India.
These troops killed thousands
of Palestinians
including many of their leaders
and the British began training
and arming Zionist militias
to suppress the rebellion, too.
But the rebellion continued.
So in an attempt to prevent further
Palestinian resistance...
the British began to limit Jewish immigration
into Palestine.
This ended up angering
Zionist extremists
leading to more violence.
So in 1947, after decades of trying
to manipulate
both Palestinian Arabs and Zionists
to keep their control over Palestine...
Britain gave up...
and handed the question of Palestine
to someone else.
“To the United Nations
also came the problem of Palestine.”
“In recent years
this small country had been the scene
of disorder and bloodshed.”
They figured, here is this new thing
called the United Nations.
Here. In your lap.
Palestine. First gift.
So the United Nations has
now to figure out
how do you disentangle
this thing...
that the British who helped create.
A UN special committee proposed
the land be divided into two states...
a Jewish state and an Arab state,
with Jerusalem
as a separate UN-controlled entity.
It was called the Partition Plan of 1947.
The plan shocked Palestinians.
We could not accept the partition plan
because at that time the population
was almost 2 to 1.
But the plan proposed giving over
half the land
and often the most fertile areas
to the Jewish state.
From a purely pragmatic perspective...
the partition plan didn't make much sense
for Palestinian Arabs.
That wasn't the only problem
with the plan.
Within this proposed area of the Jewish state...
were hundreds of thousands
of Palestinian Arabs...
including both Muslims and Christians
who had lived there for generations.
On a moral level...
the idea of making hundreds of thousands
of Palestinian Arabs minorities
in their own homeland...
seemed unjust and unfair.
In November 1947, the UN
put the plan to a vote.
In the aftermath of the Holocaust
and after lobbying from
US leaders and Zionists
the UN voted in favor of partition.
“And finally, a momentous decision
to partition the Holy Land’s
10,000 square miles.”
Britain announced their mandate
over Palestine
would end on May 15th, 1948.
Even as Palestinians continued to reject
the UN's decision to partition the land.
After the partition took place,
you know, in 1947...
you know, we really were scared
that something might happen to us.
By the end of 1947
Zionists had several well-developed
paramilitary forces...
the largest one known as the Haganah.
And more extremist militias like Irgun.
On March 10th, a couple of months before
the British mandate would end
the Haganah adopted what was called
Plan Dalet.
Or Plan D.
On paper, the main goal was to
gain control of the Jewish state
as laid out in the partition plan,
while also defending
Jewish settlements outside of the borders.
In reality, that's where the majority
of these operations took place...
outside of the UN's
proposed Jewish state.
Some carried out by Haganah and others
by more radical militias.
Many of these operations focused on
isolating Jerusalem
and the roads to it.
A set of brutal instructions called for
the destruction of Arab villages
by setting fire to
blowing up and planting mines.
Especially those population centers
which were difficult to control.
In case of resistance
it called for the population
to be expelled
outside of the borders of the state...
villages emptied
and for the occupation and control
of Arab villages
along main transportation arteries.
One of the most widely publicized
village massacres
happened here in Deir Yassin.
We lkived in Deir Yassin
which is about 4 miles west
of Jerusalem.
91 year old Dawud Assad
was there the day of the massacre
and was 18 at the time.
On April 9th, 1948, extremist
Zionist forces
executing Plan D closed in
on Deir Yassin...
even though the village had made
a local peace pact
with neighboring Jewish settlements.
Friday morning they attacked us.
Dawud escaped through a trench.
I went down, all the way down here
like this.
So about 4 hours walking
to Jerusalem.
To this day, the archive of the Israeli army
refuses to release
many of the images and intelligence reports
on Deir Yassin.
But one UN report detailed
circumstances of great savagery...
including women and children
stripped, lined up...
photographed and slaughtered.
Roughly 100 people, largely children
and the elderly
were killed in the village.
As for Dawud, he later reunited
with the group of Deir Yassin captives
in Jerusalem, including his sister
and mother.
My mother says...
So everywhere there’s a commotion,
you know?
News of what happened
in Deir Yassin
spread quickly with far reaching effects.
The Zionist militias used it
as a propaganda tool
to tell people about it everywhere.
The idea was that if you don't leave...
we will do to you what happened
in Deir Yassin.
Stories came out about women
being raped
about babies being killed
and induced a great deal of fear among
the Palestinian Arab population
many of them fleeing as a result.
“Jewish troops surrounded Arab forces
from the city of Haifa.”
After taking Deir Yassin
Zionist paramilitary groups
cleared major cities
including Haifa and Jaffa
and took hundreds of smaller
villages and towns, too.
Hundreds of thousands of Palestinians
were forced to flee
pouring into neighboring states
as refugees.
Plan D became the blueprint
for carrying out
the ethnic cleansing of historic Palestine
to make room for a new state.
And on May 14th, the day before
the British mandate ended...
Zionist declared the state as Israel.
But the creation of Israel
didn't end the Nakba.
Neighboring Arab countries
that were overwhelmed
by Palestinian refugees immediately
went to war with Israel.
“Now united and a league of Arab States...
they are insistent that the entry of refugees
into Palestine must be ended.”
The fighting lasted for months.
Arab armies eventually lost,
while Palestinians
continued to be killed and forced out
throughout that time.
Palestinians who fled often carried
only enough
to stay away for a few weeks
hoping they'd eventually return home.
A lot of them locked their doors
put their key in their pocket
and then moved to safer ground.
When you leave the house and
you take your keys with you
it’s because you're planning to go home.
In the case of the Palestinians
those refugees weren't allowed
to return.
Refugees trying to return
were often shot at.
Zionist paramilitary operations
also tried to prevent them
from returning again by destroying
the villages.
That act of preventing their return
compounded the Nakba.
So the Nakba is both the forcible displacement
of Palestinians from their homes
and lands and country...
as well as preventing them to return
once the fighting was over.
Palestinian society was
dismembered, crushed.
More than half of the
Palestinian people
became refugees, stateless,
dispossessed of their land.
Over time, the state of Israel
covered up the physical evidence
of an Arab Palestine.
Place names were often changed
from Arabic ones to Hebrew ones.
The Jewish National Fund
embarked on a massive effort
to plant thousands of acres
of pine forests and recreational areas
on top of hundreds of ruined
Palestinian villages.
Even though these forests have now grown
into big pine trees
Palestinians have not forgotten
their homelands.
While we know that roughly
6,000 Israelis
lost their lives in the violence of the Nakba...
records for Palestinian deaths
weren't kept.
It's estimated to be around 15,000.
By the end of the Nakba
roughly 750,000 Palestinians
had been forcefully expelled...
and more than 500 villages destroyed.
Though the UN’s partition plan
allotted Israel 56% of the land
through the Nakba, Israel captured
78% of the land.
It was everything except
what's now known as
the occupied West Bank
and Gaza Strip.
Today, that's up to at least
85% of the total area.
Turning 6 million Palestinians
into refugees without a homeland.
It's why around the same time
that Israelis are celebrating
Independence Day...
Palestinians are out protesting
on May 15th.
Holding up keys as a symbol
of the homes they lost
and the hope to return.
For them, the Nakba isn't just
a moment in history.
It's a catastrophe that never really ended.